ما ان تنشب حرب في مكان ما من العالم حتى
تبدا بعض المصطلحات تطفو على وسائل
الاعلام اكثر من غيرها وفي مقدمتها
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه التي تاخذ نصيبا
وافرا من العناوين الاخباريه ولا سما عند
الحديث عن احاله الملفات الحساسه اليها
للبد فيها والتي كثيرا ما تكون على درجه
من الثقل يهتز لها المجتمع الدولي باسره
اسست المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه في الاول
من يوليو تموز عام 2002 وذلك مع دخول نظام
روما الاساسي حيز التنفيذ على اثر موافقه
60 دوله من اجمالي دول الاطراف البالغ
عددها
123 بعد جهود مضنيه بدات تقريبا عام
192 لاقامه محكمه دوليه تسعى لاتخاذ
الاجراءات اللازمه لضمان عدم افلات مجرمي
الحرب من المسائله والمحاسبه كثيرا ما
كانت تصدم تلك الجهود في البدايات بمعارض
بعض الدول الفاعله وفي مقدمتها امريكا
التي نات بنفسها واصرت على ان يكون لمجلس
الامن هيمنه على الادعاء بالمحكمه وعارضت
اسرائيل ايضا لان المحكمه تعد الاستيطان
جريمه حرب للمحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه ولايه
قضائيه عالميه اذ تعنى بمحاكمه المسؤولين
عن اسوا الجرائم مثل الاباده الجماعيه
والجرائم ضد الانسانيه وجرائم الحرب وينظر
اليها على انها الملاذ الاخير فهي لا
تتدخل الا عندما لا تستطيع السلطات
الوطنيه عمل ذلك او لا ترغب فيه اساسا
اصدرت المحكمه اول حكم لها في مارس اذار
2012 على توماس لوبانا زعيم احدى
الميليشيات في جمهوريه الكونجو
الديمقراطيه والذي ادين بارتكاب جرائم حرب
تتعلق باستخدام الاطفال في الصراع اما
اكثر الشخصيه شهره ممن حكموا فيها فهو
رئيس ساحل العاج السابق لوران جباجبو
بتهمه القتل والاغتصاب واشكال اخرى من
العنف الجنسي وايضا الرئيس السوداني
السابق عمر البشير الذي كان اول رئيس تصدر
مذكره لاعتقاله وهو ما يزال في منصبه ثم
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين بدعوى
مسؤوليته عن جرائم حرب وفي عام
2015 بدات المحكمه تحقيقا دوليا في حرب
غزه عام
2014 وقدمت السلطه الفلسطينيه للمحكمه
ادله على جرائم حرب ارتكبها الجيش
الاسرائيلي لكن مع كل ما سبق وجهت الى
المحكمه انتقادات كثيره وخصوصا من الاتحاد
الافريقي وذلك بدعوه تركيزها على افريقيا
خلال العقد الاول من تاسيسها لكن المحكمه
تنفي اي تحيز وتدافع عن نفسها بقولها انها
تعمل مع افريقيا وتعمل من اجل
الافارقه كيف يعمل نظام
المحكمه يبدا المدعي العام التحقيق فور
احاله القضيه اليه من مجلس الامن الدولي
او من دوله عضو في المحكمه ويمكنه اتخاذ
اجراءات مستقله ولكن يجب ان توافق هيئه من
القضاه على الملاحقات القضائيه يمول
المحكمه الدول الاطراف في اتفاقياتها وتعد
اليابان والمانيا وفرنسا وبريطانيا من
اكبر المساهمين اما فيما يخص الهيكليه فان
البلدان المشاركه هي التي تنتخب المدعيه
العامه والقضاه ولكل بلد من البلدان
الموقعه على ميثاق المحكمه الحق في ترشيح
مرشح واحد لانتخابه قاضيه ليس للمحكمه قوه
شرطه خاصه لتعقب المشتبه بهم او اعتقالهم
وبدلا من ذلك تعتمد على خدمات الشرطه
الوطنيه لاعتقالهم والسعي لنقلهم الى
عاي l